Ja die größte batterie der welt sie ist wirklich unfasslich gigantisch
Im letzten video haben wir noch über die größte batterie farben der welt von ihnen masken südaustralien berichten heute
Geht es also noch größer die größte batterie der welt wie diese mega batterie. Genau funktioniert und ob sie die dringend notwendige energiewende
leichter zur realität werden lässt jetzt den klicks von science fiction herzlich willkommen
Erneuerbare energien sind die zukunft doch sie haben bislang einen entscheidenden nachteil
überschritt sich produzierter strom kann nicht wirklich zwischengespeichert werden für zeiten in denen es beispielsweise
Weniger sonne oder wind gibt jetzt gibt es fortschritte bei einem wirklich vielversprechenden lösungsansatz
Der weltweit größten batterie die mit hilfe von salzkavernen betrieb werden soll wenn man dem oldenburger energieversorger ewe
Glauben geht es jetzt um den
Zaubertrank der energiewende und ja ich muss zugeben wenn der plan aufgehen sollte wäre das wirklich fast zu schön um wahr zu sein
es besteht die möglichkeit etwas wirklich revolutionäres
zu schaffen sagt einer der beteiligten ulrich schubert vom centre for energy and environment chemistry in jena
Denn es könnte tatsächlich das kernproblem der energiewende lösen wir haben hier ja schon öfter darüber berichtet strom aus
erneuerbaren quellen lässt sich mittlerweile
Preis künstlich herstellen wenn die sonne scheint oder es wind gibt doch wie dann speichern für schlechte zeiten es scheint wie verhext
Weder bei den angedachten pumpspeichern, am meeresgrund noch bei pumpspeicherkraftwerken
Tut sich etwas genauso wenig wie bei anderen möglichen speichertechniken alle haben nur eines gemeinsam von einem
Großtechnischen einsatz sind sie noch weit entfernt um so mehr hoffnungen also wird jetzt in das projekt von
Ewe und der universität jena gesetzt kurz zusammengefasst die
weltgrößte batterie bei der energie in flüssigkeit gespeichert wird und zwar in sole also in salzwasser
Wenn der speicher sollen in zwei unterirdischen
Salzkavernen seinen platz finden das projekt heißt one for power und die anlage soll eine kapazität von
700 megawattstunden haben also in etwa die menge strom die etwa
75.000 haushalte an einem tag verbraucht
in planung ist diese sogenannte
polymer redox flow batterie schon länger doch jetzt
aktuell wurde ein weiteres zwischen ergebnis verkündet wie der name der mega batterie schon verrät sollen organische
polymere eine
zentrale rolle spielen diese organischen kunststoffe können elektronen aufnehmen und abgeben und das besondere sie sind sogar in
gesättigtem salzwasser stabil so die neue erkenntnis des forschungsteams aus jena zitat wir können diese polymere so
modifizieren dass sie in der sohle gelöst drinbleiben und nicht aus falls damit haben wir gezeigt dass, man
kavernen für die batterie nutzen kann sagt ulrich schubert die unterirdischen salzkavernen von denen ewe über
38 stück verfügt enthalten genau solche salzlösung auf englisch brian auf chemischer ebene läuft das dann so in zwei
salzstöcken werden jeweils tausende tonnen solcher polymer moleküle in lauge gelöst in der
elektrochemischen zelle findet dann die reaktion statt die beiden speicher flüssigkeiten namens katholisch und analyse sind getrennt durch eine membran
Und können sich nicht vermischen doch die membran ist ionen durchlässig diese können von der einen
elektrolytlösung in die andere gelangen durch die stromzufuhr von außen beispielsweise durch einen windpark gibt der katholik seiner elektronen ab er
oxidiert an den polymeren des anno lutz dagegen werden elektronen angelagert das nennt man dann
Reduktion der eine salzstock funktioniert also als pluspol der andere als minuspol
Und die aufgeladene moleküle werden dann in speicher behälter gepumpt andere
ungeladene moleküle werden hinzugegeben
umgekehrt läuft die entladung der batterie
Ab dann geben die analyt moleküle ihre elektronen ab die stehen dann als elektrischer strom zur verfügung es ist tatsächlich
wahnsinn der einzige faktor der die maximale speicherkapazität
Dieser batterie einschränkt ist die größe der speicher behälter für die
Elektrolyt flüssigkeiten ein weiterer vorteil es gibt keine selbstentladung die technik an sich ist eigentlich nicht neu
Im prinzip wird schon seit jahrzehnten getüftelt doch bislang brauchte man
Schwermetalle wie vanadium und die sind teuer das kann jetzt durch die organische polymere ersetzt werden
und jetzt noch ein paar zahlen und fakten für euch die kosten der redox flow batterie sein
mit denen von pumpspeicherkraftwerken
Sagen die verantwortlichen von ewe 70 betrage der wirkungsgrad und rund 20 tausend ladezyklen das ist eine menge
sein ohne starke effizienz verluste möglich bisher hat sich ewe allerdings noch nicht auf einen standort festgelegt dass sollen bis ende
2019 passieren in frage kommt zum beispiel
Im gum in ostfriesland etwa 50 kilometer entfernt liegt der
offshore-windpark riffgat von ewe abgesehen von wissenschaftlichen und technischen risiken die bleiben muss man
also die ersten fahrversuche abwarten bis dahin wird noch einiges an forschungs stattfinden müssen und
Vorstellbar wäre auch der einsatz der redox flow batterie in elektroautos es ist schon absolut irre was ich in den letzten jahren in der
Batterietechnik so getan hat wenn er kein video zu diesem thema gleich kommen noch 1 verpassen wollt
Dann, drückt mir hier ein abo aufs auge und vergesst nicht den
Auf die glocken und dann werdet ihr auch über neue videos informierte geht es weiter mit dafür draufklicken
Revolution super akkus erfunden dass es auch wirklich eine absolut sensationelle technik also bis dann
bleibt dran